- My boyfriend's lactose
intolerant and it was like an issue
for awhile, but we worked through it
and we're stronger because of it.
- That sounds messy.
(funky upbeat music)
- Okay, what's up you guys?
So, earlier this week, Burger King
released their Lucky Charms milkshake.
So inevitably, it's time
for me to go uptown,
snag a bunch of Lucky Charms milkshakes
and make my coworkers try
them out and see how they are.
Let's do it.
(funky upbeat music)
- Hey, can I get four of the
Lucky Charms milkshakes please?
(funky upbeat music)
- I love milkshakes.
I love milkshakes so much
I could have a milkshake every day.
I'm also super lactose intolerant.
- I like milkshakes, sure.
- I'm a huge milkshake fan.
- I love Burger King, I
love fast food burgers,
I like food that's not good for me.
- I love Burger King.
- I haven't eaten Burger
King since I was like 14.
- The ambience, the
smell, the chicken fries.
- I like Lucky Charms.
I'm in it more for the marshmallows.
- You know, yeah, I'm
pregnant, I get cravings.
Lucky Charms is in that category.
- Did you know there was
a Lucky Charms milkshake?
- No.
- If this were not tasty,
I would be floored.
- If it's soggy cereal in
a milkshake, tappin' out.
- I feel like it's
gonna be a lot of sugar.
- I see it, can we have it?
- We are excited, let's
just do this, let's do it.
- It looks like Funfetti milkshake.
- That's what it looks like.
- Looks like a party in a cup.
- But you can see like a nice
little rainbow around the top.
- I thought there would be more color.
- That smells like the frosting
you get out of the can.
- You know, they should've topped it
with marshmallows.
- Yeah.
- It's so thick.
(laughter)
- It's like if you put heavy cream
in your cereal every morning.
- Wow.
- I'm not seeing four-leaf clovers,
rainbows, balloons, pots of gold.
- Whoa!
- This thing is super good.
- Wait, can I have some more, thank you.
- Do we know how much sugar is in this?
(record scratching)
(funky upbeat music)
I don't think I want to know
how much sugar is in this
because I wanta enjoy it and not know.
- They should do Cinnamon Toast Crunch.
Honestly, 'cause that's the best cereal.
Cinnamon Toast Crunch.
- I would actually spend
my own money on this,
but thank you BuzzFeed. (laughs)
- I would say definitely go try this.
Share it with a friend
so you stop yourself
from drinking the whole thing.
- If there was a Burger King
near where I lived, I'd get this.
- I'm really into this, I support this.
I didn't think I would, I was
a skeptic, but I'm into it.
- Okay, so the reviews are in.
Some people liked it a lot, some people
didn't like it as much, it's really sweet,
tastes like a milkshake,
tastes like a marshmallow.
If you've had the Burger
King Lucky Charms milkshake
let us know in the comments
below how you liked it
and that's about all I
have to say about that.
(funky upbeat music)